-Alec Baldwin.
-Yeah.
-We asked you how
you stay in shape,
so he does 100 pushups
and 100 sit ups a day.
-Yeah.
So he came up to me
and he was like,
"What do you do?"
And I didn't want to be rude
and say, like,
"I just still have metabolism."
So I'm not, I'm not
in my mid 50s.
I just wake up like this,
so I, to make him
feel better, I was like,
Oh, man, I do 100 push ups
and 100 sit ups every day.
And he was like, "Got it."
And then and then
he got the Trump gig.
And so I would see him
every week
and every time we would run into
the hall, and he'd be like,
"Hundred a day."
And he started to do it and he
lost like 100 pounds.
-Yeah. He looks fantastic.
-Yeah.
And says it's all 'cause of me.
[ Laughter ]
-We're about to play a game
of deception called
True Confessions.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now we're going to need one more
player to fill out this table,
you know him from
"Saturday Night Live."
Give it up for Pete Davidson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow.
-Alright.
-Wow! Here's how it works,
in front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions,
one confession is true,
the other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
have 60 seconds
to interrogate you
and they have to guess if you've
been lying or telling the truth,
John, you'll go first.
Pete, which envelope
should John open?
-Wait mine or his?
-Hi.
-Oh, number two. I don't know.
-Yeah, no, that doesn't really
matter. That's part of it.
Yeah, but this
could be the liar.
The truth we don't know.
-Alright.
You got to say
or he's selling already.
Look at him.
-Are we doing it correctly?
-Yes.
Is this mine or?
-Yeah.,
-No, this is his.
-So what am I. Who am I talking
about? You?
-You're talking about you.
-Oh.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-You get it.
-Yeah. I should read the e-mail.
-Alright, gentlemen.
[ Clears throat ]
My neighbor was arrested
by the FBI for being a cannibal.
-Okay, what year was it?
-2013.
-So, cannibalism,
totally illegal at this point.
-So wait, is this L.A.?
-New York.
-Oh.
-Oh, wow. Yeah.
The FBI got involved.
How did you know they knocked
down to answer questions?
-Uh, when the FBI
was swarming our lobby
and arrested this guy
in a 6:00 a.m. raid.
-Now, did you have any clue
that he was
suspicious of anything?
-No, he never said to me in the
elevator,
"Guess what? I might be a
cannibal."
-It's freaking me out
because his voice
is like what interrogation is.
You're like, "I was there,
it was 6:00 a.m.,
-A pre-dawn raid.
-Yeah.
-Did the guy
ever act odd at all?
-He was quiet.
-Yeah.
-But he was so hungry.
-What was his name.
-I don't know his name.
-Oh, interesting.
Didn't have it.
Didn't have a nickname for him.
-No, it was a big building
in New York
so I didn't have names
for everyone.
-I say no, because if it was
L.A. I would buy it.
But I don't think people,
eat people here.
-I think it's the opposite --
-you think it's the opposite?
-I think New York has got some
crazy seedy stuff.
Oh, they'll cut your head
off here, but out there,
they will cut it off and eat it.
That's Hollywood.
-I know.
What are you going to say?
-I'm gonna say no.
I think it's false.
-I'm gonna say no, it's false.
-It's true.
-No.
-What are you talking about?
What?!
-Alright. Do you remember
the cannibal cop?
-What?
-You don't remember--
Who remembers the cannibal cop?
You remember
that story, alright.
There was a cop and he was
he was he was online.
He was on message boards
going, "I'm gonna eat people,
I'm going to kill and eat
people."
And then other people would go,
"I'm going to kill people
with you and eat them, too,"
you know. And --
-What message boards are you on?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not on these! Alright?
My neighbors and friends are OK.
So our neighbor was on a message
board with a man
who was planning to kidnap and
eat someone
with the cannibal cop.
They did a sting operation
where an FBI agent
pretended to be
another interested cannibal
who was also hungry for people.
And then he was like,
let's meet at 6:00 a.m.
and we'll go get someone
and eat him.
My neighbor goes, "Yes,"
the FBI shows up at 6:00 a.m.
and arrest my neighbor.
And we have not spoken since.
-Wow, unbelievable. Well, done.
Wow. I thought that one
was out there.
-I mean. Yeah.
-I thought that was out there.
-Yeah.
I did not see that.
-You've probably
told me this before.
-I haven't lived a full life.
There's many stories.
-Alright. It's my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
Does it matter? One or two.
-One.
-Sure, two's pretty good,
-No, I like one.
-Here we go.
I once went for a beer
with a musician
and woke up in a hotel room
in Nashville.
-Where did the evening start?
-New York.
-Yes, it's true.
[ Laughter ]
-You have to ask questions.
-Nope.
-You have to ask.
-Nope true.
I know you. It's true.
[ Laughter ]
-You have to ask questions.
-There's still time.
I think, too.
-You both know.
-What what instrument
did the musician play?
-Mandolin.
-No, just kidding. And I'm just
kind of in a guitar.
-Do you recall any of the trip
from New York to Nashville?
-I remember, yes,
getting to Nashville.
-You recall you came alert
in Nashville.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I was in Nashville.
I totally remember
that part of it. Yeah.
And then I just didn't know that
I was going to stay over there.
-Was this the first time
you met this musician?
-No.
-Oh.
-Okay.
-Is is it a one guy band?
No, that's a good question
because I don't like it --
No, like a one-man band thing?
No. It's a duo.
-It's a duo.
-A duo duo.
-Interesting.
-Yeah.
-A mandolin and something else,
but what?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-You both were just asking me
fake what you think
really happened?
-Of course.
-It's so true.
-Yeah, it is true, yeah.
-Alright.
[ Applause ]
-Guys, you should've, even
question it.
Why would you even question it?
-Because it's just like --
-It ended up happening.
-Yeah.
-We've all been there.
-Alright. Alright.
-How -- wait, so.
-It was John Rich --
-Who?
-Big & Rich.
-It's country music.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-They were on "The Bachelor"
one time.
So my reaction was correct.
-That's it we're not guessing.
-As long as I'm right.
-Pete, it's your turn.
I'm going to choose envelope
number one, of course.
-Alright.
-Yeah, that's the one.
Not one question you would get.
-Yeah
-I band.
-Lorne Michaels and I went to
Jamaica together
on vacation for New Year's.
-I really want that to be a lie.
-Lorne Michaels,
who was our boss,
who started all of our careers.
-Yeah.
-Went to Jamaica with, you?
-I went with him for New Years.
-Went with him.
-Yeah.
-When I was 20.
-I don't know if I would ever,
ever go to Jamaica with you.
I might as well go to Nashville
and wake up in Nashville.
-Yeah.
-I don't know if I'd come back.
-There's really laughing in
Jamaica that you haven't
duplicated here
in the United States.
[ Laughter ]
-That is totally true.
-Wait, you were 20?
-Yes.
-Oh, 20 years old.
-How old were you
when you began being
on "Saturday Night Live"?
-20.
-The first year?
-First season.
-Yeah.
-First season you're never
really that close with Lorne,
though.
-Right?
-New Year's, too?
-Yeah.
-Over the break.
-So this is 8 episodes in.
-Eight episodes in.
-20 years old. Yes.
-A man, your senior --
-Yeah.
-Goes, "That kid Jamaica."
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-I mean, because I could see
maybe now you and Lorne maybe
might vacation somewhere
and meet up somewhere,
but at the time,
-I mean, Jamaica? The two of
them walking around Jamaica?
I vote -- I want it to be true,
but I'll go no.
-I want it to e true,
I'm saying, no, not true.
-It is true.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm terrible at this game.
What?!
I'm terrible at this game.
How? What do you mean?
-Oh, he grew me in the office.
No, no,
he was I just he just was like,
"I'm going to Jamaica,
do you want to come?"
And I was like,
"[bleep] yeah, dude."
[ Laughter ]
-Did you guys, like, stay next
to each other in the hotel?
-Yeah, I stayed. Well, I stayed.
I didn't want to stay.
He offered to stay where he was,
but I didn't want to,
like, you know,
be me around him.
So I stayed at the hotel
ten minutes away.
So because -- I would have been
fired if I stayed there.
I have to get lead
-You have to get that much lead?
Oh, my God.
-Yeah, well, yeah,
it was a lot of fun.
-Yeah. Oh, my God.
Our thanks to John Mulaney.
Pete Davidson.
-Welcome back to the show, bud.
-Thank you.
I want to show a picture because
Kim Kardashian was on our show
a couple weeks ago.
-Yeah.
-And she showed us a photo of.
Explain this to me, so you're
out to dinner with Kanye,
is that Timothy Chow
and Kid Cudi?
-Yes.
-Now, what was
-And I am that is really me.
I'm not super imposed at all.
-That's an actual real photo.
-So, yeah,
it was Cudi's birthday
and he was like,
"Hey, let's go to Nobu." And I
was like, "That's awesome."
I'm going with,
like my manager and producer.
I was like,
"Cool, that'll be great."
So I got there a little early
so I could, like,
give them my card so it can be,
you know, I thought it was just
like us three, you know.
So I was like, I --
-You were gonna treat
with a credit card.
-Yeah. You know, you know buy my
boy birthday dinner.
-That was nice.
-You know, because he's like
the greatest piece. He's the
best musician that's ever lived.
and yeah.
And it's like an honor. Right.
-That's nice.
-So I get there
and we're outside and, you know,
we order a couple of things.
I'm like, "Hey, this is cool."
Everybody's like, you know,
skinny and whatever.
It's all fine.
[ Laughter ]
-Everyone's skinny.
-Yeah.
-"I can treat for these people."
I was like, "This is chill."
Alright, then Timothée Chalamet
shows up,
and I'm like, "Alright.
Also skinny.
It's gonna be fine,
no problem."
And then, Cudi goes, "Hey, Kim
and Kanye might come by."
And I was like,
"That would be awesome."
And then I was like, "Oh, no."
So they come by
and we're outside, right?
And then Kanye goes, "Let's get
the special room in the back."
And I was like, "Oh, no."
I was like,
"Yeah! Alright, cool, sick."
So we're sitting in there,
and I'm, like --
I'm, like, texting
my touring agent.
I'm like, "Yo, you got
to book more shows."
-[ Laughing ]
-"[Bleep] getting real
over here."
So, then, you know,
the waiter comes,
and Kanye's like --
"What would
you like to order, Kanye?"
and he goes, "I want that stuff
that's not even on the menu,
that crazy stuff."
I was like, "Oh, my God.
The crazy stuff?"
-"Crazy stuff"?
What does that mean?
-I just want to say, like,
Kim and Kanye,
the cutest couple ever.
Very, very sweet people.
I had a really good
time with them.
-Yeah, they're great.
Yeah.
But you still don't want to pay.
Like, "Dude, you're Kanye.
You should treat."
-No! Like, it was fine.
It was just, like --
It actually wasn't as bad
as you would think.
But, you know, it's not like
it's Applebee's, you know?
[ Laughter ]
It's Nobu, you know?
-It's Nobu, yeah.
-Which is like 77 Applebee's-es.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude...
Did you just pluralize
"Applebee's"?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Applebee's-es.
[ Laughter ]
-Tell me about
what you're doing.
I'm so excited about this.
What are you doing
with the new "Mortal Kombat"?
How are you involved with this?
-"Mortal Kombat 11" --
it's my favorite number.
-I love "Mortal Kombat."
-Yeah.
Also, well, they are paying me
to be here to talk about it.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah, and I --
Yeah, that's why.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's really --
-Thank you for being honest.
-Yeah, no, yeah.
You know, I'm trying to get
a helicopter to Coachella.
[ Laughter ]
They were like,
"Do you like this game?"
I was like, "Sure."
No.
[ Laughter ]
It's actually really sick.
There's this guy that
I really like to kill in it.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause he looks like
a real douchebag.
[ Laughter ]
So, there's this guy,
Johnny Cage.
-Oh, yeah, Johnny Cage.
-Yeah.
So, he does splits
and punches you in the [bleep]
is his special move.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so it's one of his moves,
yeah.
-And he just looks like
everybody I grew up with
in Staten Island,
so I just kill that dude.
[ Laughter ]
I enjoy killing him.
Also, he has, like,
a hot daughter,
which is, like, weird,
because I'm lonely
and she's, like, not real.
[ Laughter ]
So there's that
in the video game, as well --
sexual confusion.
-Sexual confusion!
With the new "Mortal Kombat 11."
-Yeah.
The effects are,
like, really good.
I'm actually wearing --
I have to shout-out,
"Mortal Kombat" sneakers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, they exist.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
They are real things.
-I like --
My dude I like is Scorpion.
-You like Scorpion.
Oh, I got you --
-That's my dude.
-I heard you like Scorpion,
so I got this for you...
-"Get over here!"
-...in case you want
to have fun with your wife
over the Easter break.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know if this
is gonna fit, but we'll see.
-No, I mean --
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, me! Oh, I see.
-Yeah. I mean, wear it for sex.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you. I understood --
I understood the first time.
Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah.
But you do love video games.
I heard you're building
an arcade at your house.
-I am.
So, I live with my mom.
Well, we bought
a house together,
but nobody believes that.
[ Laughter ]
So, I live with my mom, kind of,
so I have, like,
a basement that's, uh, mine.
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
But that's like an apartment,
so I live underneath her.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
So, like, I'm getting, like, a
little arcade setup down there,
try to make it --
try to make it a little mine.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you have?
What does that mean, an arcade?
Do you have, like,
a bunch of pinball machines?
-Well, no, you know,
I'm gonna get, like,
a "Mortal Kombat" machine.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, you're good.
No, the check has cleared.
The check has cleared.
You're good.
Yeah.
You can have "Mortal Kombat."
But, yeah, we're good.
-Okay, cool.
-So you'll get one
"Mortal Kombat" machine,
but what else?
-Well, I'm redoing
my whole entire --
So, I was calling it
The Man Cave,
but the Mulaneys told me
that if I call it that,
they will no longer
be my friend.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know.
Do you not call the basement
the man-cave?
Is that weird?
-Some people do,
but, no, you can't.
-Yeah, so now I call it
"The Basement,"
like The Ohio State University.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, it means something.
-"The."
-Oh, I don't like that college.
I just -- You know.
[ Laughter ]
It's the "The"
that's the important --
Go, CSI!
Division III.
Whoo!
-Oh, my gosh!
Division III.
D-III, man.
-D-III, baby.
-That's the real deal.
Are you gonna charge people
when they play the video games?
-Hell yeah. Absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
One of my many schemes
I'm working on, Jimmy.
-Pete, we always love
when you come here,
and I'll let you know what
happens with this guy, yeah.
-Oh, yeah, sure.
Thanks for having me.
-Pete Davidson, everybody.
-Thank you very much.
"Saturday Night Live."
This is how this works, okay?
We're gonna have
a bunch of instruments over here
that neither of us
know how to play.
And on your turn, you'll pick
a card from the board,
which will give you
a name of a random song.
-Okay.
-Alright?
Then Tariq will pick it
from a bag.
He will give us
a random instrument.
He'll then have to play the song
with that instrument.
If The Roots can guess what song
you're playing, you get a point.
-Okay.
-Enough rules?
That make sense?
-It sounds good. Hi, Roots.
-Alright. Since I'm the host,
I go first, I guess.
Alright.
Which number, guys?
We have an audience.
This is exciting.
It's such a great audience
that they all just went,
"Four!"
No one said any other number.
Out of all the numbers,
everyone just said, "Four!"
No, that's good.
I got you.
I heard everyone
loud and clear.
Okay.
Alright, Tariq, what
instrument will I be playing?
-Uh, let's see here.
Oh, you're gonna be playing
a long wooden flute.
-Okay.
I have no idea.
Alright. Uh...
Alright.
This is not even a normal flute.
This is like some weird --
-It's a long one.
I know.
I understand it's a long one,
but this is, like, a...
That's not the weird part.
I've seen long flutes before.
I just -- [ Clears throat ]
I own one, actually.
It's just the bamboo
is what gets me.
Alright.
I have no idea where to even...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, alright.
Okay, alright.
Everybody, alright.
Okay, here we go.
Alright. Alright.
Uh...
[ Whooshing ]
Alright.
30 seconds on the clock.
[ Laughing ]
[ Whooshing ]
-Is it "God Save the Queen?"
-No. Why would you guess
"God Save the --" No.
It's not a punk-rock song.
-Start from the top.
-I was.
[ Whooshing ]
[ Buzzer ]
Whatever, man.
"Party in the U.S.A.,"
Miley Cyrus!
-Oh, man.
-Turn it up!
-Wait. That was "Par--" Okay.
I was gonna say that.
-Hey, that wasn't fair.
-[ Laughs ]
No, it's not fair. Thank you.
I appreciate it, Pete.
-Yeah, man.
-Pete, you're up, buddy.
Pick a song from the board.
Yeah.
-Which one do you guys...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-There you go.
-8? I heard 7. I heard 7.
[ Shouting continues ]
Alright, alright!
-Now they're getting --
-Alright.
What do I got to do?
Which instrument?
-Okay.
Oh, yeah.
You got to play the Omnichord.
-What the [bleep] is that?
[ Laughter ]
-You can't say --
-I'm sorry.
-You can't say the F-word.
-I'm gonna guess it's this guy,
the accordion-looking
thing, right?
-The big-ass thing?
-Yeah.
-Wait.
-No, no, no.
The Omnichord is this thing.
-This? Really? Yeah?
-That's a microphone.
-I thought that was
a CPAP machine.
-Okay. And this thing's just on?
Okay, guys.
-Come on, Pete.
You got this, buddy.
-So far...
-Wait.
I think it's broken.
[ Laughter ]
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
-It's kind of dope.
-Wait. Is it going to stop?
[ Synthesizer continues ]
Wait.
-"Happy Birthday to You?"
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Wait.
-Pete, maybe slide the thing up
and down, that white thing.
[ Buzzer ]
If you slide that thing
up and --
No, the other thing.
-What thing?
No, we should actually
figure this out,
'cause that's not cool.
-It looks cool, but --
-Alright, it broke.
I don't know what it was.
It was "Brick House."
-Oh, man!
♪ She's a brick...♪
Yeah. Alright. Yeah.
-Thanks, guys.
-Dude, we got to go on
concert -- on tour together.
It's gonna be great.
-We're sick, dude.
-Alright, my turn. Here we go.
10?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
"5!"
Love it -- 5.
Okay.
-Oh, yes!
-You got this.
-Alright, what instrument
do I got?
I know the song.
-Eh, it's a new song.
-Okay, okay.
Now you got to play it
on the theremin.
That's that guy.
-That's the cool one.
That's where you just go
like this, right?
♪♪
-Are you sure
you know this song?
-Yes, I know this song.
Here we go.
-Okay.
[ Humming ]
[ Humming continues ]
[ Screeching ]
-There you go.
Unh!
[ Screeching continues ]
-"Up" by Cardi B?
-Yes! How did you...
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
-Wow, that's amazing.
-It is amazing. Yeah, thank you.
That was unbelievable.
How did you get "Up"?
-That was cool, man.
Alright, that was pretty fun.
Alright, Pete.
-I was like, "I don't know what
it is, but it sounds great."
What do you guys...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
1? Okay.
Oh, come on. Alright.
What do I got?
-Upright bass.
-Upright bass?
-Yeah.
-Is that that big one?
-Yeah, it's the upright one.
-You can do this, man.
You got this.
♪♪
-Alright.
-This is great.
-This is just something
I thought I'd never
have to do in my life.
♪♪
-Lower.
-Okay, hold on.
Lower? You think lower?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-Higher, higher.
[ Laughter ]
-This audience
is very interactive.
-Yeah. Okay.
Wait. Hold on.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-What was it? Do that again.
-Yeah, a little more.
Yeah, a little more.
-Alright, one more time.
-It's, like, something
on a soundtrack.
-"Toxic" by Britney Spears?
-We're in the realm.
-Oh, crap!
No, it was "Like a Virgin"
by Madonna.
-Aah!
-Oh!
[ Cymbal crashes ]
-Why did you say "Aah,"
like you were close?
That was --
-That was good.
-That was good, absolutely.
Madonna would be proud.
Alright, this last one,
let's join forces and do a song.
[ Imitating upright bass ]
I heard it.
I heard it in my head.
-Yeah, I heard it.
-We're going to both try
and play the same song
at the same time
and work together
to get The Roots to guess.
-Okay.
-Let's join forces.
Here we go.
Pick the song.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Yeah, let's go for 10.
And I can see it, too,
'cause it's me and you.
-Oh, this is a cool one.
-Okay, yeah, yeah, we got this.
Right? We got this.
-Yeah, for sure.
-Tariq, what instruments
are we playing?
-Guitarrón.
-The what?
-The guitarrón?
-That's all you.
You're a guitar man.
-The guitarrón and the melodica.
-The little piano?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Cool.
We just do the chorus, right?
-Yes, exactly, right?
-Yeah.
Okay. I got to blow into this?
-Alright.
-Pete, it's --
-I know, I know.
Let me guess --
it's your first time, right?
-No, pick it up.
-Hold on.
-You can pick it up.
-Dude, it's not a drug test.
It's not a drug test.
-You can pick it up.
-I can pick it up?
-How he starts his cars.
-Okay.
-Ready?
-Alright, wait.
-You got it.
-I have never seen something
happen to this guy
where it's like --
-It's COVID-friendly.
-You got to kind of
hollow out your chest?
Wait. Alright?
-One, two, three.
-Two, three.
♪♪
Let's start it from
the top again.
Ready? One, two, three.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, come on!
-Wait. Just one more time.
One, two, three.
♪♪
-That was good!
-"I Love Rock 'n Roll"?
No, "I Want You to Want Me."
-Yes! Cheap Trick.
One, two, three.
♪♪
Yeah, you got...
-Right? Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Pete Davidson, everybody!
I'm here with Pete Davidson.
Thank you for doing "Random
Instrument Challenge" with me.
-Oh, thanks for having me.
-I appreciate it, buddy.
-That was an experience
I'll never forget.
-Before we talk about anything,
I wanted to ask you about this
because I heard about this thing
that Alec Baldwin.
-Yeah.
-He asked you how to say --
how do you stay in shape?
So he does 100 push-ups
and 100 sit-ups a day.
-Yeah.
-Now, have you heard that?
And this is the truth.
You do 100 push ups and...
-No, so I was -- I was on set
and Alec was hosting
and it was a sketch
where I had to be shirtless
and like, you know,
I guess like I'm a little bit
cut or whatever.
So he came up and there's no,
like, nice way to say that.
Okay?
-I've never said that.
-So he came up to me
and he was like, what do you do?
And I -- and I didn't want
to be rude
and say, like,
I just still have metabolism.
So...
I'm not -- I'm not
in my mid 50s.
I just wake up like this
So to make him feel better,
I was like,
"Oh, man, I do 100 push-ups
and 100 sit-ups every day."
And he was like, "Got it."
And then and then he got
the Trump gig.
And so I would see him
every week and every time
we would run into the hallway,
he'd be like,
"100 a day."
And he started to do it
and he lost like 100 pounds.
-Yeah. He looks fantastic.
-Yeah, and he says
it's all 'cause of me.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, that my favorite, dude.
I wanted to hear
about that story.
I wanted your opinion on this.
This is a very local story,
but it's a big story.
New York City is now legal,
they're legalizing weed.
-Yeah.
-What do you think about that?
Any thoughts? And what --
-I think you can see it
in my eyes
how happy I am.
I think it's 12 years too late
for me and my police record.
But other than that,
I think it's a great thing.
I think like, you know, finally,
it's a cool thing for the city.
-Yeah.
Will anything changed for you?
-Well, you're a giant pothead.
-I mean, I'm just getting
the contact.
I'm feeling something right now.
But I just -- I find it
interesting.
I don't know how much
will change, I guess.
-For me, nothing.
But it is like
it's a great thing for,
you know, I think for the city
so I'm excited.
-Good.
How's everything going upstairs
on "Saturday Night Live"?
-Everything's great.
We got a Carey Mulligan
and Kid Cudi this week,
which is awesome.
-Yeah.
-You've had a great season.
You have a lot of good things
happening
I want to talk to you about.
But earlier this year on "SNL,"
you had a great sketch,
you and Timothy Chalamet
with our very own Questlove
in the sketch.
-Yeah.
-That was a big deal.
This is
one of the most viral videos
to come from "SNL" this season.
Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-What was it like acting
with Questlove?
-Oh, dude. Total pro.
Also, yeah.
It's also like really cool when
someone who like knows the show
and watches the show
and like is involved with it.
And it was just so fun
to work with him
and he got the hit me
which was cool. Yeah.
-Yeah. I saw that part.
Yeah.
-I asked him if he would
really hit me and he said no.
-He told me to hit him for real.
-Yeah.
-No.
-He's like I don't feel it.
Hit me for real.
-Yeah, I thought it would
be cool for the sketch.
-You can't have Questlove hit
you on national television.
-Yeah, but like you --
I don't know, you can usually
tell when it's a fake hit.
I wanted him to punch me
in the face.
-Hey, can I --
can I get a go?
-We need him for the sketch.
Come on.
What are you talking about?
-It would be an honor.
-You have a cool projects
coming up I got to talk about
because I'm excited about this.
"The Suicide Squad."
-Yes.
-The trailer came out
and it broke the record
for like the most --
like 150,000,000 people
saw this trailer.
And here's my man
right here from the trailer.
Pete Davidson.
-That's right.
-Come on now.
-Now that's your boy.
-That's your boy.
-Come on now.
-Yeah.
-You play the character
Blackguard.
Do you know anything
about this character going in
or how did you get involved
with the movie?
-I love, you know,
superhero movies.
I'm a huge James Gunn fan
and I got
a call from James Gunn.
He was like, there's this role
for you in the movie
and you play a guy named
Richard Hertz.
And I was like, Dick Hertz?
I'm in.
Yeah, that's his real name.
My character's name
is Dick Hertz.
-Yeah. There you go.
Yeah. Wow.
-Yeah. And I was like, dude,
that's the greatest.
That's so awesome.
And yeah, he just -- he was
nice enough to let me be in it
and like, it's a thing
I still can't believe.
It's like ridiculous.
-Like how does it feel
when that thing comes out
because the world globally saw
that thing
and they're all loving it
and so excited.
-Well, my family and friends,
like, it was the first time
they ever got,
like, super excited
for anything I've ever done.
And I was like, thanks,
I just put a movie out.
Yeah. That was about --
-That was about me.
And the family.
-They didn't care about
that one?
They want to see this one.
-Yeah.
But they were like
"Suicide Squad"
the two seconds, man.
Two seconds in the trailer, bro.
-Oh, dude. Congrats.
-Thank you.
-I just want to say
I don't know if I told you,
but "King of Staten Island,"
you crushed it, dude.
It was great and there was some
scenes where -- yeah.
And you're funny
in the whole thing.
-Thank you very much.
-And funny.
-Thank you.
There's a couple of scenes.
I'm like, go, go, Pete, go,
man, it was awesome.
It was really great.
I'm so happy for you.
And I got to talk about
the Audible original
to "The Hit Job right here.
-Yes.
-Explain this to people.
What is this?
What is an Audible podcast?
-Oh, it's an Audible original.
So it's like a movie
or TV show for your ears.
Yes.
The person from Audible
backstage is like sweating.
So it's pretty much a show with
Keke Palmer, as you can see.
-Yeah.
-And she gets a job at a company
that hires a hit man
to kill the most
the world's most dangerous man.
And, you know,
it's fun and it's dark
and like it's --
-Funny.
-Yeah, it's really funny.
-And if you're in it,
it's funny.
-It's funny.
And you don't have
to see my face,
which I heard is a lot
of people's problem with me.
-No, no, no.
-So you got to just listen
and it's really great.
And it comes out August,
August -- no, April 22nd.
Yes, I'm almost done.
-That's good.
-And yeah, there's 12 episodes.
We just love having you.
Pete Davidson, everybody.